herzlich willkommen zu diesem video ist
was richtig geiles präsidiums bei der
neue trailer zu sonic film ist
rausgekommen
da gab es ja beim ersten film shitstorm
weil der sonne gar nicht geil genug war
ich habe auch schon mal darauf reagiert
und das ist etwas folgenden beiden
kunden richtig geil erstens wurde dieser
sonic überarbeitet und der sieht jetzt
ein bisschen anders aus wir werden
gucken ob der jetzt viel besser aussieht
oder viel schlechter und mal gucken ob
sie das gerettet haben und zweitens ist
der gute djemben kennt ihr alle ja also
in kroon sprecher und dass wir haben uns
heute angekommen ich hoffe ich muss
nicht zu böse zu lernen sollen weil ich
arbeite da hin und wieder mal für crew
und ich will jetzt auch also nicht dass
der ein oder andere nächste auftritt
nicht mehr kommt so habe vorwärts auf
die stimme von zu reagieren gucken und
hast mir die visual effects davor und
danach an so saß davor aus und ja ganz
ehrlich davor sah das ding er sah
einfach aus vision zerknitterte
vertrackter
treki glock jetzt so danach aha okay es
ist geil weil eine kritik die ich ja
auch zuvor schon hatte war dass diese
augen einfach davor so aussahen wie zwei
augen und
ihr kennt ja alle hier sonic der sonic
hat ja nicht wirklich zwar einzelne auge
sagt er da eigentlich so ein auge mit
zwei pupillen drin und das haben sie das
besser gemacht und beide augen viel viel
größer gemacht auch näher
zusammengebracht und erst jetzt einfach
ein bisschen freundlicher aus west ihre
augenfarbe haben sie auch gut geändert
und er sieht einfach bisschen mehr
katholisch aussieht wie man so
realistisch aus aber finde ich also
nicht die fee geiler wenn ich auch immer
extrem dankbar dass die der scanner ist
auf jeden fall nahe es ist viel
sympathischer jetzt aussieht
der kleine sonic sieht jetzt aus wie so
ein lieber kleiner also der andere
sonnig sein wird so aus als hätte das
herz von xphone absturz gehabt wäre so
ein rockstar gewesen das war der falsche
nicht recht aber viel besser viel
sympathischer
ich finde auch extrem cool von paramount
pictures das die da einfach gesagt hat
okay wir hören auch das internet wir
machen das jetzt einfach so wie dieses
wollen und nicht so ja okay wir machen
das hat alle im unrecht ich finde es
extrem geil dass der scanner haben
wirklich wenn man jetzt noch sieht der
neue trailer im englischen hat es auch
schon wieder 19 millionen klicks
innerhalb der letzten drei tage gekriegt
also ich glaube fast deswegen dass der
sonnig erst so schlecht aussah und jetzt
plötzlich so geil aussieht hat der
insgesamt viel mehr promo einen gefahren
als bekommen hätte wenn die hallte es
von anfang an cool gemacht hätten
vielleicht was auch marketing gag ich
glaube nicht okay wir gucken uns jetzt
den deutschen trailer an mit tollem in
der synchronstimme ich wusste dass gar
nicht mich hat das komplett überrascht
wenn ich auf jeden fall kreis ist immer
so eine heikle sache wenn hatten youtube
in diesem grund stelle übernimmt youtube
sind dann einfach keine synchronsprecher
profis aber wir gucken sie doch mal an
und schule ist direkt sonic nicht mal
eine nebenrolle sondern wirklich aber
sonnig das ist und um meine welt zu
retten musste ich auf eure kommen
[Musik]
wo bin ich warum ist es hier so dunkel
was sind das für level fans ein bisschen
komisch weil immer kennt halt schuh auf
seinem youtube videos waren warum
alberto wobei der nicht immer rum aber
man kennt alle und jetzt ist er
plötzlich sonnig und immer wenn jetzt
sonic geredet habe ich das gesicht vom
kopf und ich glaube das sollte einfach
nicht so sein
war das schreiben auch von tu ich weiß
nicht ob es nur daran liegt dass ich
erkennen dass es sie deswegen bisschen
komisch anfühlt ich gebe ihnen genau das
[Musik]
hat mir das mein gott
nach dem trailer jetzt habe quelle
geschwungen aber das onyx sie wirklich
dass das mein gott ist das rechtswidrig
zeigte mal wieder dass ich will mal
wissen was er wie lange er da geübt hat
und ob da wirklich professionell
geschult wurde kann ich mir gut
vorstellen auch wenn sie jetzt
vielleicht nicht perfekt ist wenn sie da
auf jeden fall dass er echt besser ist
also normalen entwickelt ich werde
gleich mal ausprobieren wie ich das
visier und dann seht ihr mal wie krass
eigentlich das ist was studer gemacht
hat vielleicht finden parallel ist nicht
so cool dass das synchronisierte dann
sieht den ball bietet ein kompletter not
machen würde und wie schrecklich es sich
dann an gehört hat wird das wird spaß
dass das problem jetzt lange aus das
wird spaßig
das gut versichert oder
[Musik]
wie hast du das gemacht ich heiß der
wortwitz oldesloe jetzt hund oder eine
kugel ist wie hast du das gemacht ich
habe keine ahnung
es müsste mal vorstellen sonic ist
einfach so einer sondern richtig fetter
blockbuster so einer der größten filme
die uns halt dieses jahr 2020 geben wird
und schon spricht einfach die hauptrolle
das recht ist es also respekt anjou
dafür dass das mittel
und ich werde meine freunde damit und
kegel preis zu schützen
du bist also toms bester freund von
de-mail abad also wie gesagt ich bin so
trefflich dass er das macht ist hat auch
jeder an seiner stelle gemacht hat
niemandem gesagt ich finde man hört ein
bisschen raus dass er kein absoluter
profi ist gerade jetzt im direkten
vergleich lasst uns geht oder es wird
zeit gerade im vergleich zu den anderen
wenn man den vergleich dann hört man
einfach ein bisschen stark dass er herrn
motto ist ich weiß ja dass schlechtes
ist wie gesagt ich weiß nicht ob das was
schlecht ist ich weiß nicht ob es daran
liegt weil ich einfach kennen oder weiß
seine videos aber besuchte ich komme
auch die kommentare an was die leute
dazu sagen das ist ein schlag ins
gesicht für marcel stachel dem
eigentlichen deutschen synchronsprecher
für sonnig naja ich finde bewundernswert
was team erreicht hat aber die stimme
passt nicht wirklich zum charakter naja
irgendwie bisschen druck weil ich weiß
auch dass er sich diese kritik pult drei
heftig zu herzen nehmen wir teil gibt so
viele youtuber den ist scheißegal was
alle von ihr denken aber auf jeden fall
nicht aber natürlich muss man selber
wissen bevor man seinen heftigen auftrag
annimmt aber ich glaube wie gesagt in
auftrag hat auch jeder angenommen auch
jeder einzelne dieser kritiker hätte
diesen auftrag genau so angenommen und
die jetzt noch viel schlechter gemacht
und um ihr zu zeigen wie geil das was du
gemacht hat eigentlich ist im vergleich
zu einem kompletten werde ich erst mal
110 raussuchen und selber darüber
sprechen wir dann gucken wir mal wie
sich das anfühlt okay ich hab noch nie
irgendwas synchronisiert dementsprechend
als auch richtig peinlich wo wenig ich
kann einfach nicht kennen würde
so bin ich warum ist es ist dunkel das
ist okay jetzt der queens der queen von
queens wo bin ich warum ist das jetzt
dunkel was ist das für ein film
es passt also überhaupt nicht alle also
wie gesagt noch immer jetzt kritisiert
das ist verdammt schwer es ist verdammt
schwer
wo bin ich warum ist es jetzt runkel was
ist das es passt halt einfach mal
überhaupt die leute ok nächstes beispiel
du bist also toms bester freund du bist
also thoms bester freund von dem er wird
okay
mal gucken es wird es wird wieder
unangenehm es wird wieder unangenehm
leute
mal an du bist also toms beste freund
von de mail aber es wird einmal
überhaupt nicht passen also du bist also
toms bester freund von dem erlbad george
braque jetzt im vergleich zu mir hört
sich deine stimme an als wärst du der
größte profi überhaupt
[Applaus]
das hast du gerade sie ist es mein
tunesischen fleck im einsatz
das sind übergänge die einfach per drag
and drop auf deine videoszenen kannst
und sie sofort deutlich spannender zu
machen ohne dafür irgendwelche
vorkenntnisse zu brauchen für blogs
let's play oder sonstige videos wenn ihr
daran interesse haben dann schicken die
linke der video beschreibung ab wenn er
generell schneiden werden möchtet dann
könnt ihr auch meinen zwei stunden
schnitt kurzen video beschreibung
abchecken wir suchen auch nach wie vor
für unser projekt entwickler also wenn
ihr das könnt und vox ab dann guckt man
eine video beschreibung steht wir euch
wie werden könnten diskont link für alle
anderen die an dem rpg minecraft break
interesse haben und dann wenn er mich
auf dieser reise begleiten möchte dann
abonniere gern diesen kanal und dann
sehen wir zunächst mal wieder macht's
gut
[Musik]